hello everyone and welcome to the
semi-finals of the opera you were rapid
knockouts it's magnus carlsen versus
maxime vashir lagrave and already we
have
another clash of uh who knows uh their
stuff better uh it's another
uh groomfield masterpiece now we just
have to check if it's a masterpiece on
how to play against the groomfield or
how to play the groomfield
so uh without further ado let's check it
out magnus carlson with the white pieces
opens
with d4 uh we have knight to f6
uh we have c for g6 and knight to c3 and
the d5 so the groomfield defense is on
the board
and we have a trade in the center
captures captures and now not e4 as we
uh we usually see but here magnus goes
for bishop to d2
so preparing to kick away the knight
with e4 next and then if this knight
captures then
bishop captures and c3 comes and then
this bishop is uh
very nicely developed and will be able
to counter blacks
black's bishop and g7 so here bishop to
g7 magnus pushes e4 and now
not captures but rather knight to b6 and
this is a
very well known line for both of them so
they just nicely continue the
d4 pawn is under attack so bishop to e3
defending it twice now and maxine
castles with
h3 by magnus and e5 now striking in the
center asking do you want to go d5 and
then i'm going to undermine your pawn
with c6 or uh do you just want to defend
it so here magnus just defends it we
have f3
and e captures on d4 bishop captures
offering a trade of dark square bishops
and
knight to c6 so this has all been played
before nothing new here
uh bishop captures on g7 offering a
queen trade maxime traits captur sunday
one
rook captures and king captures on g7
and now bishop to b5 threatening to ruin
black spawn structure here on the queen
side so knight to b4
uh and now comes a3 pushing back the
knight tonight to c2 check of course
doesn't really do anything if you
deliver this czech king d2 and then your
knight is trapped nothing to
to do here so after a3 uh first
we have a6 pushing the bishop back so
then you can retreat with knight to c6
or you can just trade everything
but that's not really something uh white
is looking for so bishop back to e2
knight back to c6 and now comes knight
to d4 and this is a new move there is a
uh well-known game between laquan liam
and the vladislav artemia from the 2017
blitz uh
tournament in china uh where uh castles
was played but here like i said we have
knight to d4
and it is uh as of move 16 that we have
a completely new game so it's a
a quite uh a long familiar line we have
knight capture sunday for
rook captures and the bishop to e6 now
maxime just wants to play
uh rook to d8 uh and the trade off the
rooks along the d
file and he equalized he doesn't really
have anything to worry about so magnus
castles
rook after d8 offering a rook trade and
the magnus doubles up on the d
file rook after d1 maxime trades ones
captures captures
and now you can see that the material is
completely equal both players have a
knight bishop six pawns
but magnus for the moment controls the d
file and
uh maxim has to do something about this
as uh well the
the player who controls the open files
will have a much better game so maxine
starts with king to f6 he wants to bring
his king to e7
so he can play rook 28 and trade off the
the pair of rooks with f4 by magnus
using this opportunity to grab more
space here the pawns nicely control
everything
and making room for his king to also
enter the game so king is seven
preparing rook to d8 and now comes king
to f2
we have rooked the d8 and now king the
e3
magnus wants the trait to happen here so
he can further improve the activity of
his king
we have rook captures on d4 uh king
captures and
now f6 not allowing the white king to go
any further
we have h4 by magnus and now comes
knight to d7
and this knight the d7 is not the
perhaps the most precise way to
play this with black but unless you know
exactly what to do here it's not
all that easy to find a move here with
black bishop to b3 seems like an idea
taking away some of the squares from the
white king
also very interesting is just a5
preventing b4
in the future uh and also if king the c5
then you can just go bishop d7 and you
have all of the squares covered
the the white king cannot approach and
if bishop to b5 you can just go back
bishop to e6
and it's uh it's a very nice position to
play for black but okay and maxine went
knight to d7
now maybe with ideas of playing c5 but
magnus
stops it in its tracks he pushes b for
himself and it's always a special moment
in every game
where someone plays b4 so here h6 by
maxime
just um uh strengthening the position on
the king side and
here uh magnus goes a4 uh there is the
uh the idea of maybe going knight to d5
check if the bishop captures then you
further improve the
position of your king you can even
capture with the pawn but maybe better
with the king
and if king d6 then it seems like you
have this knight captures on f6
knight captures an e5 check but it's a
very unclear what does white really gain
from it captures captures
and you still i don't have a good way of
entering the game king c5 and all of
these squares are covered so your king
isn't really going anywhere
and if you want to continue pushing then
a4 and so on so instead of going for all
this magnus
starts with a4 and he says i always have
this let's just improve the position
as much as we can first so here g5 by
maxine
and now g3 just defending the pawns g
captures on f4 g captures and now
uh knight to b8 by maxime and this is a
classic
case of um of you know uh digging
digging your own grave this knight is
never leaving the b8 square the knight
had to come to
f8 and then from fa the the knight would
be able to join
in the game uh depending on what white
plays maybe via the e6 square maybe via
the g6 square maybe via h5 and then
via the f6 square but after this knight
to f8 move
uh there is uh really no hope for this
knight and here magnus goes for it
knight to d5 check uh and now the both
of these pawns are under attack so you
have to trade here
bishop captures with e captures taking
away the c6 square from the knight
and now comes the b6 but now uh feel
free to pause the video and try to you
know get the feel of the position uh
your magnus here what would you play
black really doesn't have much but best
not to give him anything so
feel free to pause the video what do you
play here with white while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
taking uh away any hopes of black
surviving this and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show
it's not a five it's actually h5 with h5
this knight is uh forever stuck here and
there there are no hopes uh the the
knight cannot go here if you go here
you cannot go here or here if you go
here you cannot go here
so everything is taken if you go here
you can't go here so just a terrible
terrible position for
uh for black and also it uh kind of
creates a way
uh for example if if the black king and
the knight are attend to the queen side
then you have a very clear way of
entering the position with your king
so not a lot for black to do here maxime
tried a5 but magnus just captures here b
captures b captures and now king to c5
and now what do you do here uh for the
moment the knight and pawn
are covering all of these squares but
how do you defend this knight there's
simply no way to do it
so maksim tries f5 uh another thing you
could have tried is maybe knight d7
check but like i said king c6 now this
pawn is under attack
and once the king defends it bishop to
f3 you defend this pawn because
knight to b6 is coming but yeah it
doesn't really matter king
king to b5 to a the captures on a5 is
coming and there's nothing black can do
about this
so instead after king to c5 we have f5
by maxine
but now just uh bishop to b5
taking away the d7 square from the from
the king and even though maxime is
one minute up on the clock uh maxine has
some five minutes on the clock magnus
says four
but it doesn't really matter there are
no moves for maxime left
uh and uh here king to d8 is played
again if you go for knight to the d7
check here magnus just trades it's not a
problem captures captures king b5
and they both will get a pass pawn and
push their pawns but maxine calculates
precisely that
it's simply impossible but i will show
it as it comes down to one tempo king d6
king captures on a5
king captures on d5 uh and now after
king to b5 making room for the pawn
now comes c5 uh pushing the pawn
or you can play c6 check and then c5
doesn't really matter it's the same
a5 c4 a6 c3 a7
c2 and it seems like black is queening
but white queens with check and that's
just it once the king moves
uh you can just play anything just cut
off the king from reaching the pawn
defend c1 and that's just game so here
after bishop to b5
this is impossible maxine played king to
d8 but now magnus just played knight to
d for a akink to d4
uh and it was in this position on move
36 that maximum shallow grave resigned
the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
the king will just uh gobble up all of
these pawns and there's nothing you can
do about this this knight can never
enter the game
once you play this the bishop just
trades and then it's a completely
completely winning king and opponent
game you can try something like this but
just captures captures king e5 and
that's it you gobble up the pawns and
black has no hope whatsoever of
surviving this so of course the maxim
knows this and here uh he resigned so
another
another brilliant example of maxime
going for his uh
groomfield against magnus for i don't
know what time already
and he completely neutralizes every
threat uh magnus has so this is how good
uh maxime is in this but somewhere at
this point uh
after all all this has been done so this
holds for black everything is perfectly
fine
but here already one slight mistake and
then
at this moment uh when we said that the
knight should have come to a f8
this is just a game over after the
knight comes to b8 that's that's just it
and we we might even use this as a
thumbnail
since this is definitely the uh where it
all went wrong for
uh for maxine uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it uh i would like
to thank
alexander graf a mystery person ladies
and gentle nicholas hoffman and michael
zakarias for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the semi-finals checking up
on your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day